now I'm often asked here on the air
about reverse mortgages and 100% of the
time I've told people to not do reverse
mortgages good article in The Washington
Post over the weekend and I tweeted out
the link over the weekend a guy tweeted
it to me actually is where I found it
and I sent it back out and listen to
this as she was getting on in years her
resources dwindled Virginia Rayford took
out a special kind of mortgage in 2008
that she hoped would help her stay in
her three-bedroom Washington row house
for the rest of her life
Rayford 92 took advantage of a federally
insured loan called a reverse mortgage
that allows cash-strapped seniors to
borrow against the equity in their house
that has built up over decades but the
risks of the financial arrangement are
stark and today the frail widow finds
herself facing foreclosure under the
terms of the loan Rayford can defer
paying back her mortgage debt that
totals about four hundred and sixteen
thousand until she dies sells or moves
out she is however responsible for
keeping up with the other charges namely
the taxes and insurance on the property
the loan servicer Nationstar Mortgage
says Rayford owes six thousand and four
dollars and unpaid taxes and insurance
and if she cannot come up with it she
stands to lose her home in Washington's
Petworth neighborhood I've cried a
million nights wondering about what I'm
gonna do Rayford again she's 92 years
old said across the nation an increasing
number of seniors are facing foreclosure
after taking out reverse mortgages
either because they fell behind on
property charges or failed to meet other
requirements of the complex mortgage
loans according to the federal data and
interviews with consumer and housing
specialists the Federal Department of
Housing and Urban Development HUD which
ensures most reverse mortgages in the
country says it lacks details on the
data detailed data on how many
homeowners have lost their homes or
facing foreclosure in the program by the
way is alive they don't lack details on
it which was launched in 1989 and covers
about six hundred and thirty six
thousand loans and Nationstar the lender
on this case declined for comment
kidding but a HUD report issued HUD who
doesn't have detailed data issued a
report that found that nearly 90,000
reverse mortgages held by seniors were
at least 12 months behind in payment and
taxes and insurance were expected to end
in quote involuntary termination I don't
think I want to be involuntarily that's
correct that's that's federal
bureaucrats speak for we're gonna shoot
you in the face
involuntary termination oh my god that's
a scary phrase Oh in 2017 that's more
than double of the year before but let
me help you this folks okay let me walk
you through some numbers there's six
hundred thirty six thousand these loans
out there ninety thousand of them are in
default headed to foreclosure
that's fourteen percent of the loans are
failing as astra Freakonomics
still he said reverse mortgages are a
critical resource for seniors who wish
to access their accumulated home equity
and age in place thank you for the HUD
spokesman for figuring this out they
have a completely failed loan program
that is causing senior adults to lose
their homes at an unbelievable record
but his answer is it's a critical
resource for seniors who wish to access
their accumulated home equity and age in
place you sound like a lobbyist dude you
know sound like somebody they can add
before 2015 the only thing homeowners
ages 62 and older needed to qualify for
a reverse mortgage was equity in their
home lenders weren't required to
determine whether they could afford to
maintain their homes or cover the taxes
and insurance payments in the future
since homeowners used the funds to pay
off the original mortgages or ran out of
money after covering living expenses
over many years now HUD requires all
borrowers to undergo a financial
assessment Wow before we give a mortgage
we actually do a financial assessment
guys are rocket scientists unbelievable
listen to this tens of thousands of
troubled loans remain more than eighteen
percent
of reverse mortgage loans remember where
earlier figure was 14 currently more
than 18 percent of reverse mortgage
loans taken out from oh 9 to 2016 are
expected to go into default because of
its 1 in 5 because of unpaid taxes and
insurance according to a HUD report that
compares with less than 3% of federally
insured loans in the traditional
mortgage market so your typical FHA loan
about 3 percent of them go bad 18
percent of these reverse mortgages are
going bad I told you these things sucked
representatives of the National reverse
mortgage lenders Association decline for
comment well I would run and hide behind
the biggest Bush I could find advocates
of the loan including celebrity
spokesman such as Tom Selleck and Henry
Winkler say reverse mortgages can help
seniors enjoy their later years no they
don't really say that they read a script
borrowers can receive listen there's the
terms of reverse mortgage ocation in
them borrowers can receive 50% to 66
percent of the value of their equity
depending on their age and interest rate
and the interest rate generally set
about 5% now why do I tell you not to
get reverse mortgages because you're
gonna lose your home potentially because
you get into all kinds of problems
and because the interest rates and the
fees are a really bad ripoff you ever
heard me say that before
ok so let's hear what they just said
interest rates are generally set about
5% you know what the going rate on a
15-year fixed is today a traditional
mortgage a HUD mortgage do you think
it's do you think it's 5% anybody
anybody out there you think it's 5% I
get a report every morning I'll tell you
what it was this morning 3 and 1/8 so
you're paying almost double you old
people that are getting ripped off thank
you Tom Selleck and Henry Winkler we
appreciate your endorsement you have the
opportunity to pay double and
potentially lose your house when you're
92 this is a dadgum mess people
unbelievable
for example the a 73 year old with a
home worth a hundred thousand and no
current mortgage could receive a loan or
a lump sum on monthly installments up to
a line of credit for
250 $7,900 not including cozen costs
according to HUD so you can take your
$100,000 house and get 60 grand out of
it and potentially lose it it's anybody
listening to this unbelievable the
federal consumer finance Protection
Bureau has long warned about deceptive
advertising and reverse mortgages in
December the federal agency fined three
companies American advisers Group
reverse mortgage solutions and Aegean
Financial for alleged false claims
saying they told seniors with reverse
mortgages that they would not have to
make monthly payments or face
foreclosure omitting the risks of
failing to pay property charges these
companies tricked consumers into
believing they could not lose their
homes with a reverse mortgage said the
bureau director the companies did not
admit wrongdoing in settlements that
required that they pay seven hundred and
ninety thousand dollars in fees one of
the companies was American advisers
group which is where Tom Selleck's says
he speaks on behalf of them many older
Americans are in a tough spot right now
why not use a reverse mortgage to make
sure you completely lose your home oh no
that wasn't what he said I put words in
his mouth excuse me
hey guys telling you for years reverse
mortgages suck there's all your details
interest rates are double the
foreclosure rates are Eightfold this is
ridiculous answers the question run this
is the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
you
[Applause]
[Music]